yolande c'est squeeze aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur plants vs
zombies c'est parce tu m'as
personnaliser un petit peu notre
personnage dans un premier temps je
propose de lui mettre cette petite coupe
de cheveux qui est quand même pas mal
ridicule
on peut le dire avait non mais c'est pas
la même déco n'est pas adéquat non ça
suffit
au niveau de la pilosité faciale ont
accueilli m ça voilà c'est comme ses
cheveux mais sur le bouton et je propose
un beau attentats parce qu'on ya mis
il a rien vu le pois chiche il a fait
beau la voilà c'est le mode de jeu
contre joe caqueta pois chiches à paris
qu on a tous trois compétences spéciales
et en face il ya un truc qui
complètement rôle où il joue de
compétences il envoie un espèce de
guarico rouge donc tu dis au chili con
carne je vais te manger et la chaleur
faut-il préciser que le haricot en
question fait un mètre sur 50 cm
regarder le lui le petit hameau la
salive à me défoncer allez petit
fumigènes pour toi c'est bon mais après
l'objectif
j'ai fortement aidé mon équipe j'étais
vraiment sur l'objectif et où je pense
que sa maman il n'aurait pas eu à quai
c'est que ce chapeau monsieur mais oui
vous êtes mort le ridicule tue mais oui
et je compose de faire boum attendait
ceci est un satellite ou une noix de
coco coupeurs de feu
bon déjà c'est aucun des deux c'est une
antenne ou noix de coco par satellite à
les cailloux tu vas être mon ami c'est
l'homme au chapeau ridicule je
regarderai on va lui mettre un au plat
très bien sans tuer personne
tout était prévu voilà y compris ça
alors lui et ce qu'il aime bien regarder
les gens mourir je sais pas
et bravoure ira pas moi je veux faire un
jump jump in the cailloux et le haut mon
dieu qu'est-ce qui a le pois chiche
qu'est ce qui l'a le pois chiche évident
allez on appris la base sans corps gras
savoye bâtard il s'est mis en retrait
regardez le mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ce pourquoi as tu des godes cuisine
jeune homme a pour cuisiner les pois
chiches peut-être voyez je ne sais pas
blake était nul
ok barbecue qui me rejoint à d'accord
bon je vous avais d'avoir vécu les mecs
livraison à domicile qui veut serein
maroc c'est gratuit je paie les
saucisses il vous payez les flics tu es
cette blague est bien trop longue à les
jeunes cactus
ouais c'est pas par là qu'on passe pour
journée barbecue déjà donc je ne te
permets pas donné elle a un moteur sur
la tête d'accor cette plante ainsi un
problème après bon les plantes font ce
qu'elles veulent à m 81 face j'aurais
pas dire allez voir je te fais un bisou
en fait ça non c'est ce à quoi est ce
qui va se dire la tête là et que sa
ventouse
ok je viens en paix pour passer à
arroser les plantes au le pois chiche
j'ai repéré il prend la fuite dans le
toboggan
ça paraît tellement bizarre de jeunes
tout comme ça mais l'espoir entré dans
le temps au temps mais j'avais tout mon
corps et mon nom c'est la guerre qu'est
ce qui fait l'homme blasé mais regardez
le haut non regarde pas comme ça
je crois que c'était bon tu veut se
taper trois jeunes plants et bim
jamais encore il se croit tout permis
mais c'est toujours le même et non mais
tu vas pas prendre mon toit non plus il
est content il est content de lui je met
une fugue gêne sur ce toit voilà de
cactus à la pro je m'en souviens le
retour du cactus à l'afro tu pensais
l'avoir
eh bien tu m'as eu donc là les petites
croiser domec mort on peut les
ressusciter mais vu que je suis un jeune
gros bâtards je le ferai pas on va a
manqué un zombie comment j'ai flashé sur
toi oh je vais te suivre tu vas me
protéger jusqu'à la fin
notre avis alors déjà il faut d'abord se
faire le tour allez à + moi j'ai des
géraniums un rosé non pour la
renaissance et cap sur l'objectif il
noie 5 secondes
je pense que c'est jouable attention au
moins se faire une plante avant la fin
on gagne des pièces à la fin de chaque
partie là je m'achetais un bac de folie
et à chaque fois que je lis non ça fait
penser à la folie que vais-je donc à
boire ou j'ai une vignette de personnage
rare juste là le personnage le plus
viril de la planète
il est carrément pas viril du tout moi
je propose de jeu mandeure voilà on a
personnalisé
voilà on va lui mettre les piercings
hors norme fictive order [ __ ] on
dirait carrément un [ __ ] de bon coach
j'arrive les enfants regarder le luxe le
fait non mais le poids est cassé ce
qu'on peut faire c'est arrivé par
derrière son match contre aux bâtards et
mourir digestion digestion voilà hop hop
voilà tu es porter mes crocs dans ce cas
ce n' est aussi maintenant nous allons
jouer le cactus mais attention pas
n'importe quel cactus de cactus
électrique
je propose de mettre mon petit drone
s'est delahaye et voilà alors là je suis
carrément vulnérables j'ai cinq points
de vie c'est comme si dans la réalité je
voulais me battais que j'étais une
chaise comme non il m'a vu il a vu un
morceau died en ciel il a fait je vais
devoir de jeu tu passe carrément pour un
psychopathe je vais sur le drapeau pu se
passer entre les balançoires et puis là
d'un coup j'ai vu une sorte de zombie
ingénieurs du coup je vais lancer les
aiguilles dessus des aiguillons
électrique est alors j'ai invoqué des
noix de cajou
ça n'a aucun sens si tu parles de ça en
cours à tes potes et les gens écoutent
et regardent comme ça dont je refais
personnage
donc je ne suis pas là je ne suis pas un
morceau die qui vole je vais mettre des
planes domine on va et combien quelqu'un
marche sur la mine
on va planter une plante un tape shui
elle sa vieille dent qui dépasse là
allez je te couvre tout va bien tout va
bien mon enfance je fais la poule
enfants j'espère que tu t'en sortiras
dans ce monde de brutes sans moi dans 3
secondes et demie les morts le pois
chiche à tanger une technique
sa technique suicide mais moi je trouve
ça bien aux haricots rien il est là il
est là et boum
mais non mais vas-y mais tient les
haricots les haricots et moi chaque fois
la ric hochet pas quand ils font mal et
je vois jamais puisque c'est comme ça je
m'en fais sur mon vélo a new day 4
et là je fonce et pois chiche regardez
delilah j'ai connu car d3 bon dieu
c'était un vrai génocide
alors les pinots ça se fait pas sur la
tête et cette plante c'est un peu ce
code d'experts actuellement parce que
elle fasse en mode riom solaire est là
ça marche vraiment bien et s castagnou
desquels recherche de haut comme elle
est mignonne attend arrêté dans la tempe
et jordi barre c'est comme ça je fais
d'abord une jacuzzi hop là avec ce bed
bien monsieur cactus ce cactus sa blague
pas avec wahaha
s'il ya plus de 500 vix qui rentre dans
la baraque on a perdu 20 mai l'iran par
milliers patrice aux côtes mais sûrement
par milliers tendez mais là c'est
carrément de partir en guerre mondiale
c'est la défaite mais qu'est-ce qu'il
fait sont bi tenté de se compliquer le
moins du monde je ne comprends pas
pourquoi je commence à aller j'espère
que ça vous aura plu on se retrouve très
bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo je
tenais à 22 sur je me suis quand même
vraiment marre en a plus oui maman oui
les